The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from 100 of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: Hi, Pablo.
PABLO SUAREZ: Good to be back.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
Nice having you here.
So we wanted to
talk about a number
of high-level postmortemy
things for how the class went.
So we've got some high-level
things we wanted to talk about.
We want to talk about the
collaboration between MIT
and the Red Cross/Red Crescent
group and your folks--
how student preparedness
went, in particular, comparing
those teams that got a lot of
support, like client support,
like Snap, of course.
But also, some of the other
teams got a little bit more,
and then the
unsupported teams, which
aren't exactly unsupported,
but they got less,
so that's largely
the Heatwave Team,
I think was the main one that
we want to talk about there.
So collaboration what do
you all think about how
we talked to each other?
How we met with each
other-- things like that?
PHILIP TAN: I like
the way how we
started in the beginning
of the semester.
We had to talk-- and we
had some Skype issues.
But I think the idea of
kicking off the entire class
with the initial
presentation of this
is what your final
project is going to be.
It's going to take us
a while to get there,
but you come into
class understanding
this is what it's going to be.
And Pablo being the
person to describe
why this is going
to be important,
I think, set lot of
expectations well.
So I think later on, when we
actually got to that project,
the degree to which
each team actually
could have been
supported actually
became more of an issue.
The teams that you could
directly talk with--
and you were going to be the
primary user of the game--
clearly benefited.
But you were right there
from the beginning.
These are the teams that,
maybe, they did receive support,
or some of them didn't
receive support,
but weren't talking
with people who
had been there right from
the start, I think maybe
had felt a little
bit more disconnected
from the main
thrust of the class.
At least when they got
to that final assignment.
So something I like to think
about for future classes
is the extent to
which-- if we're
going to repeat this format--
where the primary client comes
in right at the beginning to set
the tone for the entire class.
How do we represent more of
the variety of different things
that you can do right
at the beginning?
So that when students
think about what they're
going to be doing throughout
the entire semester,
they are actually keeping full
scope of the project in mind,
not just the one example that
might be presented to them
on the first day of class.
PABLO SUAREZ: And
we also may want
to have something like
an engagement meter.
Because I wasn't
aware of the fact
that some teams were
feeling disengaged.
I would show up, some
people have questions,
some other have less questions.
And from my perspective, those
who have questions I spent time
and it was about the same
chronometric time per group.
I could see that
some were more lost,
but I wasn't aware
that what was needed
was more fire in their belly.
So if we could--
RICHARD EBERHARDT: I
couldn't see that either.
PABLO SUAREZ: Right.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: The students
never reported it to us.
SARA VERRILLI: Yeah,
I was going to say,
when we asked the students
to do their postmortems,
they were really clear about how
this had been a big motivation,
and interest had been
a big problem for them.
But they never mentioned it
to us during check-in meetings
when we were doing play testing,
when we were working with them.
So that's the sort
of thing that we
need to-- probably
one of the things
you do is probably to
warn them about that.
These are hard topics, and
they can become boring topics
very quickly.
And they need to step up and
let us know when they think
they're facing a brick wall.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: I think
the clues were there.
If we had means and a
way to remind ourselves,
like a checklist or something
simple like that, just to say,
are you engaged?
What's your motivation?
And, again, that's
assuming that we even
want that to be our job.
I think for anything
client based,
it has be our,
probably, our job.
SARA VERRILLI: I
think that when we're
asking them to work on projects
where they have relatively
little control over the topic,
I think we actually do need to.
Because I think part
of it was I don't
think the teams knew
how much freedom they
had to deviate from the
topic they had chosen
and the specific.
They thought they had
chosen this thing,
and now they were stuck with it.
Even though one
team was like, we
chose a topic that just
wasn't deep enough.
There wasn't enough there.
And if they had come
and talked to us,
we could have given
them the freedom
to well, go change to a new
topic, or how can we go--
RICHARD EBERHARDT: Go deeper.
SARA VERRILLI: --how
can we go deeper in it?
Right.
But we were not
sufficiently warned.
PHILIP TAN: But
that's where rapport
with someone who knows a lot
about the domain can help.
And if they don't feel like they
have that rapport or someone
who they can readily contact
to ask even seemingly
silly questions,
then we're not going
to be able to get
down to actually ask
the important questions.
Because sometimes
they can't tell.
They can't necessarily tell what
looks like flagging motivation
on a part of the
team or what just
seems like end-of-semester
pressures on the students,
right?
They haven't been working
on enough projects
to be able to tell
the difference.
And so we do need to help
them through that, I think.
SARA VERRILLI: By that you
mean the students, then?
PHILIP TAN: The students.
I mean the students.
PABLO SUAREZ: And one of the
things you may want to consider
is we know that both in the
real life-- in the future,
in their future, as well
as in future courses--
there will be limited
ability of those
who are experts to interact
with the game design team.
The game design team,
you took the effort--
and I thought it was very
well-balanced-- to have some
who know programming, some
who know narrative, some who
know user interface, and so on.
They will, by default,
not have expertise
on heatwaves or cholera
or etc or climate science.
They cannot assume that
all they need to know--
including the appetite
for engagement--
will be only in the client.
MIT is a bubbling powerhouse
of engaging stuff.
And if they could, as part
of what they are told-- they
will have to do in
the future, and what
they have to do in this
course, to reach out
to engaging people, fellow
students, and junior faculty
or whoever may give them some
time-- to just go and say,
what is exciting about this?
What are the cutting-edge areas?
What are the
institutional challenges.
So that they also have to
fuel their own appetite.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
Having an assignment
or having part of that final
project being like here's
the research component
that we expect you to do,
but we didn't put an
underline over it.
SARA VERRILLI: We didn't make it
explicit that they needed to--
RICHARD EBERHARDT: We did
when it was in trouble.
Like for Saving Gora Gora,
they were in big trouble.
We told them a number-- you
told them, we told them.
I think you'd be surprised
what they came up with.
Because they actually, I
think, they took the baton
and went with it.
SARA VERRILLI: They
did that [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP TAN: Nice.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: The
other cholera team did not,
and they were given
the same-- almost
the exact same-- feedback.
That is the thing.
PHILIP TAN: I think there
is a huge social barrier
between the undergraduates
and the rest of the institute.
The noble laureates, and
even the post-docs here,
that's a lot of social
pressure keeping students away
from that kind of interaction.
You're all right.
All of these things do exist
here at MIT, but some of this
is reinforced by
professors themselves--
professors who keep
their doors closed
when they in their
office, things like that.
And so I do think we have
to do give them the license,
and sometimes that's pointing
them to specific people.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: Yeah, giving
them resources like here's
a list.
One of these might
pan out for you.
The others might not.
And that's OK, just do what you
can, kind of prime them for it.
PHILIP TAN: It's hard to be
a teenager in this space.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
Actually, since we're
talking about the
student preparedness
in that research like what we
saw between what we consider
the supported teams versus
the unsupported teams, which
may or may not be fair--
could be the motivated
teams versus the
unmotivated teams.
Snap, in particular, really--
PABLO SUAREZ:
[INAUDIBLE] correlation.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
--really well-supported.
They actually reached out to
you all for help with the game.
You actually even did testing
for them that was actually
coming from you and
Jana, yeah, because you
were running workshops.
PABLO SUAREZ: Right.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: How did those
workshops run-- how did you
interact with the team?
PABLO SUAREZ: So,
first of all, I
think it's important to
distinguish not only what you
are calling supportive
versus unsupportive,
but also Snap versus
everything else.
Because Snap was a
game concept that
preexisted the course
that needed refinement
and digital interface.
So from that perspective,
it's not surprising
that they have something
clearly defined that they
could run faster and deeper.
And the group was a group
that engaged and went
deep and went fast.
The interaction
we had with them,
also, very importantly,
we have events
that we could use the product.
So it was much easier
to give feedback
saying when we do
this, we expect
people that would get bored, why
don't we try this other thing.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
It's milestones,
which we give them milestones.
But there is no
weight behind them.
These ones have an actual,
if it doesn't work by then,
someone's going to have
egg on their face, right?
PABLO SUAREZ: And from that
perspective, we know this,
but we can try to do
more of giving students
more proportion of work that
we know-- that we, the clients
know-- that we have milestones.
And that is limited by
how much of the real world
gives us milestones to abide by.
But we can try that.
I do not feel comfortable with
the label supportive versus
unsupportive because it sounds
like some got time and support
and some others didn't.
I think it's more about the
form of the relationship
and how the time was used or
the opportunity to use the time
was used.
Because I have no doubt that
you supported the team when
you knew support was needed.
And as far as I know, the
same was true on our part.
I think it's more
about having sensors
about when support is needed
that is not being delivered.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: I think
when we're talking about them
in this way, I'm
using it based on how
they describe their
own relationship
and their own experience.
So that the teams who we
are calling unsupported
are the ones who, in
their postmortems,
called out and
said, we didn't feel
like we got client support.
They got the same amount.
It was a different
way, different quality,
different quantity.
SARA VERRILLI: The way to put
it is the same amount of support
was there for them.
One other way to put
it is they didn't know
how to reach out and get it.
They didn't use
the resources that
were there because,
at some level,
we weren't pushing them at them.
And a lot of MIT courses tend
to encourage students to solve
all their problems themselves.
They don't want
them reaching out.
They want them--
figure this out.
And so it may come
as more of a second--
it may not come to them as
first nature to go, hey,
we need to go and reach out
for more help and grab that--
RICHARD EBERHARDT: And so
that's actually the same thing.
So what we saw with
the Snap team is
we wanted-- the feedback
they were getting from us
was look at your front
end, look at your UI.
We wanted to see a lot
of changes on the UI.
Because they were working
on these milestones,
they were really worried
about the back end
so they were doing a lot
of work in the back end.
They were getting two
different messages,
and they chose client message
rather than instructor message.
Totally OK and totally viable.
We took that into account.
But I think the
main issues we had
with them is when
they got our message,
it was, they heard it early on.
They didn't react to it until
it was too late-- had they
done a little bit
extra in the beginning.
So one thing I think we need
to think about with the class
is thinking about how are
we helping them understand
how to prioritize feedback?
Right?
What's more important?
Could be because
here's something that's
actually going to get used.
It could also be here's a lesson
we want to make sure they get.
I think they got the lesson.
They just got it
in a harder way.
PHILIP TAN: Sometimes they get
a lesson at a point of time
that they can't
actually execute on it.
But hopefully they can do it for
their next project after class.
Something I want to
suggest, actually,
because we've been talking
about how it's been difficult
for us to figure out what's
going on inside the teams.
We can see the games
and the testing,
but the team dynamics, we
don't find out about that
until near the end of the class.
And something that we used
to do outside of this class,
but in our research
work, was to get all off
the scrum masters together
on a regular basis
to just do an exchange of
information with each other.
They don't even have to be
necessarily reporting to us--
although we can
moderate those sessions.
It's more about them sharing
their experiences with each
other, and then it may make
it more obvious that there are
resources out there that some
teams are taking advantage
of and some teams aren't.
Of course, we can use those
situations for teaching,
but also for
teaching each other.
SARA VERRILLI: Creating
some group, group support.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
We talked about that
before this semester started,
but we couldn't figure out
a way to do that fairly.
I already feel
producers bear the brunt
of the work in the class.
They're the ones we
see all the time.
We don't see the students
working on programming
or design as much.
Design a little bit
more, but programming,
we just almost never see them.
SARA VERRILLI: And we let
the teams use the producers
as their face-- so giving
all the presentations,
giving all the reports,
answering questions when
we ask questions in class.
Think about how we convince the
teams to share out that work
a little bit more evenly.
PHILIP TAN: Well,
perhaps, maybe, we
can reduce the extent
that we require
these producers to do
presentations in class,
and replace that with these
more closed-off sessions
where they don't feel like
they have to be on stage
and put on the best
face for their team.
They can actually just talk
about this is the problem
I'm having with my team.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
So one thing I also
wanted to make
sure that we talked
about what was it like for you?
How much of your
time did we demand?
Was it a lot compared
to other projects?
Was it a little bit?
Was it about moderate?
PABLO SUAREZ: I want to start
by saying one of the things
that I really appreciated
was the time we spent--
both face-to-face
and emailing and so
on-- before the
beginning of the course,
to have understanding of
what you and your students
can offer, what we
need and can offer,
and to manage
expectations, as you said.
I think that was very well done.
And it's not always the case.
So with the students and
professors and Red Cross,
in general, we
[INAUDIBLE], so thank you.
That was really appreciated.
I think that amount of time
that I personally had to give
was about as much as I
anticipated, about as much
as I think is reasonable
to expect for the future.
We do have Jana, in particular,
and a few other members
of the team-- of
the Red Cross team--
who were available
to give a hand.
And I think we needed
to improve because I
did make it very
clear that I couldn't
get five emails per
day asking questions.
But to have some kind of ability
for the right contact when
either engagement levels are
too low or mega confusion
levels are too high or sense of
purpose is diluted and so on.
So to refine that.
I think it would be
better to think of times
when there can be slots
of decided interaction
between each team, and someone
from the client organization
that doesn't have
to be during class.
Because I would always
interfere with your plan.
You gave us one
opportunity that I
thought was very useful,
but a little bit late
in the development process
and also very crammed.
By the time we
said, OK, these are
the kind of things you
can do, there was no time
for them to think
and reflect on,
OK, we can do A or B
or C. Show that to us,
and then us providing feedback.
So even if it were one
more chance via Skype
but scheduled, planned, and if--
it is in the nature of our work
to have to travel, and it
is in the nature of our work
that travel timing changes
outside of our control.
So where there's a default
date, and if things have
to be changed, it is changed.
So to know that there's going to
be an instance of feedback that
may be too little, too late,
still but to anticipate that.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: Yeah,
part of that is the students,
we don't always know
the student's schedules.
So it could possibly be
planned in the beginning
of the semester.
But planning it
before the semester
would be really difficult.
Unless we just say it--
this is the time that
you're going to have.
If you don't take advantage
of it, you don't get it.
PABLO SUAREZ: Right.
It has to be we
propose it's this week.
This is the default time slot.
If not, that time slot, agree
on a different time slot.
And then it's up
to the students.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
So you're actually
saying you would have talked
to them a little bit more.
PABLO SUAREZ: If
the problem was lack
of engagement or perception
of lack of support.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
So it's really
that planning and scheduling.
So as long as that's
in place, then the time
is there, because
it's been planned.
OK.
PABLO SUAREZ: And
also I think it
would have been nice for them
to have access to, say, someone
from the Ghana Team to
look at the color, someone
from the Heatwave Team in
Buenos Aires-- to at least
to get a flavor, there's
another human being there that
eventually can use their game.
And I didn't do enough
to help them envision
the user-- either
the Red Cross user
or the community level or
policy or government user.
PHILIP TAN: I think we
need to state that strongly
that it's not just the
information that you're
providing.
It's the fact that there is
a real person who can really
benefit from the work
you're doing is much more
powerful than some sort
of abstracted audience.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
So we provided
plenty of documentation,
but that's not
the same as a human being.
PHILIP TAN: That's not
the emotional drive
that you're going to
get-- oh, someone is
counting on me doing good work.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: So
maybe it might just
be something for us to talk
to the Terrascope folks
to see how they do that.
PHILIP TAN: Well,
they specifically
get people who can commit
on regular meetings.
And the idea is--
my understanding
is that it's for the
domain knowledge primarily.
But you get that
side benefit of here
is a real human being who's
excited about this problem,
or maybe really concerned
about this problem,
and that can influence
the motivation of a team.
PABLO SUAREZ: And also, I
don't know to what extent
we can keep cramming
what students have
to do-- I know they already
have to do way too much--
but to look at how
that kind of field
is currently being communicated
in the game universe
and outside of that.
So PowerPoints or documents,
they're, across the board,
generally boring
and unsuccessful--
even if they have
the right content.
So for them to get a sense
that if someone really
needs to create
awareness on that topic,
and this is the best
they have in what
exists in the real world, how
about trying to give something
that makes people want to
do more through their game?
PHILIP TAN: I think saying, this
is how low the bar is, can we
get it slightly better, is
less motivating than saying,
what's the best you can do?
RICHARD EBERHARDT: But it's
also choosing something
that's going to get used.
Why go in a direction that's--
if this is what those people
are thinking about, if you give
them something completely not
like that at all, they're
probably not going to know what
to do with it.
PHILIP TAN: But I mean,
I can imagine things
like evaluating current
methods of teaching
about a certain concept, to be
part of that research process
that we've been talking about--
it's understanding the problem.
RICHARD EBERHARDT: Cool.
All right, so I think it's
about time to let you go.
But thanks so much
for coming in.
PHILIP TAN: We thank you.
Huge gratitude.